the international criminal court has
sentenced former ugandan militia leader
dominic ongwen to 25 years in jail for
war crimes and crimes against humanity
hongwen became a commander of the lord's
resistance army
after he was abducted by the group as a
child he was convicted on 61 counts at
the hague in february
a judge says he ordered the killings of
civilians and abducted children
in the chamber's view no imprisonment
for a period shorter than 25 years
could constitute an adequate
proportionate and just
joint sentence in light of all the
relevant circumstances of the present
case
at the same time such a joint sentence
acknowledges
dominic ongoin's unique personal history
and safeguards the prospect of his
successful social rehabilitation
and consequently the concrete
possibility of future
reintegration into society christophe
deteca is
an expert was an expert witness in the
trial of anguin
and he says the length of the sentence
is a surprise
it's higher than what many people
expected it's higher than what the
prosecution asked the prosecution
asked for 20 years
and he got 25 years
also it's clear that although his
experience as a child a child soldier as
being abducted
was in mitigating circumstances it
wasn't taken into consideration for his
culpability they said well the gravity
of these crime status
they deserve much more than 20 years
they would deserve life sentence
but because of these particular
circumstances were given 25 years
and not all judges agree agreed with
that one judge said
well because of this gravity i'd prefer
to give 30 years so he didn't want to
take these personal circumstances
into accounts there are some voices who
say on the defense team they are utwell
somebody like dominic on gwen he should
be tried according to
traditional justice mechanisms there's
for example a cultural
judicial magazine mechanism which is
called mater
put but the icc rules no we cannot take
this into
consideration the sentencing has to take
place here
other voices argued well first of all
it's difficult to say that there is
one voice of what people in northern
uganda say
some people would say let him sit out
his sentence in the hague but let him
also come here to uganda and let him
apologize